so as joe moeller mentioned amari's body
was found
literally within walking distance of
where he was reported missing
and that's where we find 8 news now
reporter victoria saha live from the
segal suites victoria
yep i'm right here at seagull suites
where i saw amari's body being taken
away
it's within walking distance of the
emerald suites right over there
and it appears his body was found right
behind that wall
over there the scene at segal suites was
blocked
off with many people living in the area
watching as they say they've been
following the disappearance of amari
ever since it happened
there were many tears shed by complete
strangers as amari's
body was being loaded up we kept hearing
them say i love you amari
one woman i talked to had just been at
the wash up at cambridge recreation
center where they were doing a search
for amari
as soon as she heard he was recovered
she rushed to the area at segal suites
because
she says she didn't want amari to be
alone
he's just a baby he was alone and you
know
all these people came out because we
care about him and even though we
weren't we didn't know him and we
weren't close to him
you know he's still always going to hold
a special place in our heart
several others who lived in the building
also seemed very shocked
tons of emotions here today but i also
want to add as the scene here was
clearing up
a crowd gathered at the mcdonald's next
door would it where
it appeared taylor nicholson amari's mom
was being talked to by police again it
was a very
brief encounter but a crowd did gather
and they kept
yelling and saying that she should be
arrested as well
reporting live from segal suites
victoria saha 8 news now